bonjour je m'appelle Angélica riquebourg
société AIG création je suis
organisatrice et coordinatrice de
mariage j'ai créé mon entreprise le en
novembre 2013 et ça fonctionne pas mal
alors l'originalité la force c'est la
qualité de mes
prestations de la coordination ce que
j'emmène à mes clients en fait parce que
je cherche du haut de gamme et il y en a
très peu sur la Réunion c'est pour ça
que je me suis principalement intéressée
à l' challenge parce que ça me
permettrait déjà au côté organisation B
avoir du monde avec moi au moins une
assistante et puis ben enfin enfin
comment vous dire
ça et élargir
mes mon entreprise sur la
décoration bonjour béatrand paillette je
présente ma société m sa propre 974 la
société a été créée au 1er octobre de
l'année 2013 c'est une société
d'entretien de surface en hauteur et
plus spécifiquement pour les panneaux
photovoltaïques alors c'est un entretien
très particulier nous nous sommes
renseignés auprès des précurseurs dans
les panneaux photovoltaïques donc les
Allemands et les Américains qui ont mis
au point depuis maintenant plus de 25
ans un système bien spécifique de
nettoyage de ces différentes surfaces et
nous avons fait rentrer une machine
l'année dernière qui consiste à rendre
de l'eau pure donc de l'eau du robinet
totalement pure par un principe
mécanique qui peut être aussi chimique
nous on évite le côté chimique donc
c'est un souci de d'écologie on va dire
pour respect respter un petit peu le le
cursus du de l'énergie renouvelable donc
voilà on a des particules d'eau qui
sortent d' d'une machine bien spécifique
ce qui permet d'avoir un
entretien optimal de ces différentes
surface je m'appelle rbert Anita j'ai 28
ans et j'habite à saint-bunoir en fait
je fais sandwier à
brasfusé euh ben dans les zone urbaine
et voilà ça fait presque 2 ans je suis
euh dans cette domaine en fait ben je
fend que sandwi pour l'instant et j'ai
envie déà d'investir dans repas euh ou
euh euh de premi nécessité parce que
j'ai euh j'ai mon entreprise au-dessus
du meuble j'ai travaillé 18 mois en CDD
et après ben fatigué chercher un travail
parce que tout le temps c'est maintenant
c'est pasist temp donc du coup ben j'ai
décidé de créer mon entreprise voilà
mais c'est pas facile les clients ben il
motiv de de continuer parce que ben
c'est client ça ve dire que les gens
aiment sa
voilà